[Music]
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
that donald trump was flushing down the
toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumps
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
[Music]
bathrooms
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring my mangoes
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
fully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy
to be healthy
[Music]
a ser oh and i'm am i muted no i'm is
this
no i'm kidding i i'm messing around we
have had some serious audio issues
lately
and uh i will i will address that it's
almost as much of the show as the
content just me having audio issues and
different uh
different things but it's great to see
everybody we have so much to talk about
i have something very very special for
you guys today and it's not just another
coupon code okay so i'm actually i'm
actually glad you're here today as
opposed to on many streams where i'm
like what are these people doing it
makes no sense um okay
there is a federal investigation of
hunter biden happening now you might say
oh is it the laptop is it about windows
updates is he using uh [ __ ] instead of
photoshop and what kind of stickers does
he have on the laptop no
no it is about none of it
so let's read about what's going on and
then i'll give you my take on it
federal investigation of hunter biden
heats up okay
a justice department investigation into
hunter biden's business activities has
gained steam in recent months
with a flurry
a mcflurry of witnesses providing
testimony to federal investigators and
more expected to provide interviews
the probe led by the u.s attorney in
wilmington delaware started in 2018
it concerns multiple financial and
business activities in foreign countries
dating to when biden's father was vice
president
investigators have examined whether
hunter and some of his associates
violated money laundering tax and
foreign lobbying laws as well as firearm
and other regulations
you know what i say about this guys
have at it joe biden shouldn't get
involved i don't care about hunter biden
if he committed crimes charge him
if you get a guilty verdict throw him in
prison i don't care i don't care about
hunter biden it has nothing to do with
joe biden's administration now
i should add
hunter biden has not been charged with
any crimes and has denied wrongdoing it
has nothing to do with the laptop that
the blind tech
found it just it just has nothing to do
with it okay
this is something that dates back to
2018.
his father joe biden is not being
investigated
according to sources who have been
briefed
but the ongoing investigation has
persistently raised questions about the
ethics and behavior of hunter biden and
it has fueled right-wing political
attacks guys i don't care
investigate the guy i'm not going to
defend him if he did something wrong
then throw the book at him file charges
it just
it you know it's like what are joe
biden's accomplishments as president uh
we can talk about that is joe biden
doing a good enough job on ukraine or
kovit or whatever
let's discuss
hunter biden come on guys come on give
me a break it's just not uh
it's it's joe biden is right not to get
involved and let the investigation
happen that's it it's not it's not like
uh
just investigate that's it there's no
conspiracy that's it
um
welcome everybody
we are going to be looking at shortly
an interview i did
just an hour ago
with a pro-trump
michael flynn and roger stone endorsed
candidate i think you guys are going to
find it very very interesting very very
interesting let's look at a couple of
things as some of you know audio
problems continue to plague the live
streams if you missed the monday stream
this is what you missed
laughs
wait a second you guys can't hear
anything now
oh that doesn't make any sense
what the hell is going on with my audio
guys
oh wait a second
what about now
wait a second
could people hear it when i changed
something because now i don't want to
have messed something up in all
seriousness now i don't know what people
are hearing i just don't even know
you couldn't hear it before
you couldn't hear but okay fine fine
okay good all right so anyway that
happened fine let's move on also in
mango news it looks like there's some
pretty good deals on mangoes under the
biden regime this is an advertisement
someone posted to our subreddit um
who said uh mangoes back down under
biden your mango dreams come true five
for five bucks that's a very good deal
that's at whole foods market also and
they even have a passover menu going so
that's big
that's big big big
um
okay
very good and i have for you guys
kaylee mcinanny went on kirk cameron's
show kirk is this actor former actor
current actor i don't know
and i guess she was trying to talk about
antidotes
and instead she kept saying anecdote
it's really weird check this out
now let's see if you can hear this well
a biblical truth that i believe jesus
christ the savior that i believe that
jesus christ um is the way to heaven i
mean these are my beliefs i've had my
entire life so i understand feeling that
way as a christian um but we gotta be
bold you know the anecdote to to darken
the anecdote and i love how the the
subtitles say antidote anyway it's like
guys she's saying that it's the anecdote
this is light and uh the anecdote to a
really grim future is filling the world
with a lot of christian babies um who
could bring that light to the world dear
god so very very weaponized stuff there
from uh kaylee mcinanny and we will
momentarily move on to a very very big
deal interview let me address wow what
is happening here uh super chat's coming
in papi says david do you believe if
ukraine wins against russia democrats in
congress will win the midterms i don't
know that i would draw such a close
connection pappy not sure about that
chakaseki says i'm worried about
kawthorne's republican cocaine orgy
allegations is he insinuating that
there's an eyes-wide shut-style
adrenochrome party i think he is
i think that is exactly what madison
cawthorne is uh suggesting okay
when we get to we are now within
striking distance of 100
000 twitch followers when we get there
we are going to do a multi-hour twitch
only open phone lines town hall it will
be our first ever twitch town hall we're
at about 90 000 followers on twitch
right now when we get to a hundred
thousand we will do a special event
twitch only no youtube no facebook no
uh
no getter no grinder no tinder no rumble
just twitch and we will open the phone
lines and we will just take call after
call and let all the all the twitch
viewers uh tune in
that's at 100 000 twitch followers we're
at about 90 000 right now even if you
normally watch on youtube make a free
twitch account and just follow us on
there so that isn't that that is a a
heretofore yeah we're not it's not going
to be on grindr absolutely not
um and we will give away my gavel that's
right we will be doing we're going to be
doing all of it when we reach that level
so that's very exciting uh bay photo if
the department of justice pursues
charges on hunter i'd hope to set the
president it would set the precedent for
prosecutors to charge trump and family
i'm just saying
that's an interesting perspective
better buy yourself a bag of mangoes
before the price goes up very much so
yeah i'm going to be investigating the
price of mangoes very seriously all
right let's get to the interview first
let me make sure i've thanked everybody
i want to say thank you to my bag of
mangoes jay tandaway ryan rincon captain
smiles with two subs and harry which
already puts us at six i also want to
tell you guys about something else
the gifting of memberships on our
website is live
and it is spectacular
on monday by popular demand we installed
uh
a module on our website which when you
sign up for a membership lets you check
a box which says this is a gift okay
now if you want to gift a membership to
someone specific you can type in their
info if you leave it blank you allow me
to give it away and we've given away 22
memberships since monday now if you want
to request a free membership just go to
davidpakman.com
free membership oh so hold on is it free
or gift membership damn it now i don't
remember
free it's free okay so you've got to
fill out a form i received 15 emails
from people saying david i'd like a free
membership those go directly into the
trash
if you want a free membership you fill
out the form at davidpakman.com
free membership there are currently
227 people
now 228 who want a free membership we're
just going in order okay this is so
simple and yet so many people
were completely disoriented they were
visibly confused like trump at his
rallies if you want a membership fill
out the form at davidpakman.com
free membership now 230 people we j
we're going in order i'm not playing
favorites
if you want to gift a membership
you go to joinpakman.com
you go through the process you check the
box that says make this a gift
but don't give it to anybody specific
okay guys so for example
john roberts uh oh wait no that's not
that's not right hold on
oh these are people claiming their
membership sorry sorry sorry sorry these
are not new
people are claiming memberships from
monday okay fair fair fair
uh here we go
brian wrestler just gifted a
subscription so that puts us at seven
and so now
adelaide foster
gets a membership is this clear
gift received you gift one someone gets
it we're just going in order so adelaide
you'll get an email after the stream
with info about how to claim your free
membership
every gift is given to someone i hope
this is clear brian wrestler just gifted
another one okay so that's number eight
and now
who's next
tommy smith
gets a free
membership i hope this makes sense guys
brian wrestler gifting another one
that's number nine
so now
jesse valentine gets a free membership
brian gifts
and jesse goetz
man
okay
let's continue
lastly real quick thanks to beardlik
sarah chris dean cleo cabeca lin and
gooby that's five people signing up via
twitch puts us at 14. let's get into the
interview there's so much to talk about
guys i don't want to delay anymore
talking about this
many of you came to me and you said
david
you've got to do more of these
interviews with the crazy right-wing q
anon types
and so my colleague john
came up with a list of some of the
wackiest candidates
and started reaching out to them the
first one we had scheduled for last week
the woman canceled too bad
but now
we've done an interview
i am going to pro this is not going to
be on our podcast until next week it's
not going to be anywhere for a while i
am going to preview the interview with
you right now
okay
do people want to see this i think it's
completely insane this interview
do you email to get a free membership no
do not email do not email about a free
membership all right let's just get
right into it let's just here we go okay
speaking with a republican congressional
candidate named darlene swaffer and i
think this is going to be very very
interesting for our audience darlene is
a small business owner and is running
for congress in florida's 22nd district
uh darlene i really appreciate you
coming on today
thank you david thank you for having me
yeah and it's you know i'm always
interested in learning more about
different candidates their ideas whether
there might be you know my audience is
on the left and it's always interesting
to see where there might be
opportunities to sort of bridge divides
and work together and all of these
different types of things so let's kind
of contextualize your candidacy a little
bit
um if i understand correctly michael
flynn and roger stone have both endorsed
you is that correct
that's correct and a few hours before
our interview you posted a picture of
yourself with the with the former
president donald trump and and you said
it was wonderful to meet my president
just as a sort of like gut check right
who's the current president of the
united states
uh i don't know that's debatable some
people feel that we had a stolen little
election uh oh first question is who's
the president we're already i mean
she's she spoke
she said five words and we're already
off the rails and that's an illegitimate
president currently serving um you know
i have my own thoughts on that but
if you if you look back in the last
uh
one year and several months where are we
as a country i mean we went from being
energy independent to now purchasing oil
from russia and negotiating guys is the
question who is the president considered
a gotcha question oil with venezuela
we went from having very low inflation
to having very high inflation
uh we got back into the paris accord
even though we are very responsibly
a global citizen on our energy
consumption well let's get to that but
darlene i want to hold you to who's the
current president
well
i don't believe that uh the current
president is a legitimate president and
we'll leave it at that is joe biden
currently the president even if you
think he's illegitimate is he the
president
i don't believe he is i don't believe
that is the current legitimate president
can you guys imagine huh
we've got we've got a sick country guys
and who is the current legitimate
president
um
i don't i don't believe we have a
current legitimate president wow so in a
sense there's no president of the u.s
right now
i guess that's your interpretation of
what i said
[Laughter]
are we are or is this are we liking this
so far guys i mean i can cut it or we
can keep going if you guys want
um
it's i mean it's pretty wild i'm not
gonna lie
people say keep go okay all right let's
keep going but okay
will you tell me i mean is there a
president right now i guess
um
well
i i'd rather not answer that can you
imagine preferring not to answer whether
there is currently a president
it's insane
because i kind of feel like you're
leading down an area of controversy
uh yeah i'm i'm goading her into saying
something crazy with the question
is there currently a president that we
don't have to go
okay interesting
um let's talk about the energy
independence thing just to pick one
thing and so this i think will give my
audience a lot of kind of insights into
your into your campaign now i'm gonna
warn you guys we talk about oil and gas
for about eight minutes
and it gets really bad really really bad
so if you're allergic to cringe i'm just
warning you guys you may want to go
um
the
united states in 2020
which was donald trump's last year in
office produced as much oil as we used
and i think that's what you're signaling
when you talk about being energy
independent we we used a certain amount
of oil and we produced an amount that
matched that
and in 20 hey by the way i have to take
issue there's one person on twitch
saying that it's an idiotic line of
questioning for me to ask her
who's whether there is a pr
guys
it's it's itty it's monumentally idiotic
to be a candidate and to be unable to
say if there is a president and who it
is
i'm sorry i don't agree with that when i
see insanity
i explore it further
so the the fact that she's unable to
answer
is the idiotic part okay let's continue
21
the same thing happened we produced as
much oil as we used so can you tell me
on what basis you say that we are no
longer energy independent under joe
biden
well actually if you look at the graph
of how much oil we've purchased from
russia it's significantly more than what
we were producing for ourselves i mean
that graph was well published and i'm
happy to email that to you
but that is an inaccurate statement that
you just shared it doesn't matter how
much oil we consume we can either
produce our own oil
and build back our reserves which is
what president trump did
or deplete our oil reserves and start
purchasing oil from other countries
which is evident in the price of gas
today i mean it was under two dollars a
gallon a year and three months ago and
what are we at now four dollars five
dollars in some cases six or seven
dollars that is your evidence let's get
back to gas prices and i want to really
with you i love the clarity of the
conversation where let's let's agree to
first talk oil and then we'll talk gas
so
did you know that the u.s for decades
has purchased oil from foreign countries
so under trump even though we produced
as much oil as we used some of the oil
we produce we export and to make up for
that we import some oil and under both
trump and biden we imported oil from
russia did you know that
um did you know that in the last 20
years we had presidents in the united
states that did not focus on energy
independence and producing our own our
own oil and offshore those opportunities
to other countries did you know that
well but that's not an answer to my
question that is an answer because it's
not about the trump presidency what
trump did was create energy independence
to the point where we were exporting oil
okay that's not what happened in
previous uh presidential administrations
but you criticized joe biden for
importing life from the obama
administration and license the clinton
administration it allies to the bush
administration it was both democrat and
republican this escalates significantly
i'm just warning everybody like we we're
still we're still going down the hill at
a very fast rate of speed here you're
going to see where this goes and
presidents that did not look out for the
interest of american families and what
trump did was put american families
first we have the capability to farm our
own uh reserves from
gas coal and gas but darlene if we can
uh if we can darlene i really want to
take it one issue at a time i want to
take it one issue at a time
will you concede that in both 2020 and
2021 u.s oil production exceeded
consumption will you concede that and
then we'll get to the disagreement will
you concede actually it's not a
concession we did produce more oil oil
than we consumed but that's because we
were able to export it and actually earn
income
back to the treasury on what we exported
now we're no longer in an exportation
phase we are purchasing oil from other
countries because we're not producing
enough oil let's see i don't want to
belabor it but at the same time i want
to make sure my audience understands
where where we're disagreeing in both
2020 and 2021 let's see if we can even
break it down more simply darlene
in 2020 the u.s used a certain amount of
oil well you will you agree that we used
oil in 2020. look in order
this is this is amazing i have to keep
break we're like
we can't talk about
we can't talk about the element we first
have to break it down into
its component atoms and like that wasn't
simple enough so i've got to break it
down into like quarks and right i mean
it's like we have to keep going it's
like baby talk okay so let's let's
explore now
of course okay we use oil will you agree
we used oil in 2021
we did use oil in 2021. good
will you agree
that in both 2020 and 2021 forget for a
second about exports we produced more
oil than we used in 2020 and 2021 are we
okay on that
right but but hold on just let's get to
it we'll get to it but right we agree so
far right right okay in both 2020 and
2021 we exported some oil
right yes and in 2020 and 2021 we
imported some oil from russia
we imported very little oil i don't have
the chart in front of me but we did
import some right right and we had to we
had to produce more oil because our oil
reserves were depleted under the obama
administration trump put back our oil
reserves during his administration would
you agree to that no i don't agree to
that but let's but let's get to that
we'll get to the disagreement so so far
darn this is great because we're really
going through the nuts and bolts we both
agree
that in twenty you can tell how thrilled
she is to be going through this
sequentially 20 and 2021 the u.s
produced more oil than we used and we
agree that in 2020 and 2021 we exported
some oil and we agree that in 20 and 21
we imported some oil from russia so
what's the big criticism of what biden
did in 21 it sounds like it was exactly
the same thing
well actually
we didn't purchase oil to the extent in
2021 like we did in 2020 or 2019 oh so
biden was more independent he didn't
purchase his money
purchased oil in 2021 that we did not as
a country purchase all right so she's
next she's it's complete you know at
this point i realized there's nothing
else
we've made the point so now i move on
pretty soon
in 2020 2019 2018 and 2017. oh he
purchased four years under trump's
administration we did not purchase the
oil from russia to the extent of what
biden has done got it 2021 okay that is
fact okay all right let's talk a little
about gas prices
who's responsible for high global gas
prices right now
who's responsible for high global gas
prices if we are producing our own oil
we can control the market behind the
prices
that's economics 101
okay
but so right now would you agree that
gas prices are high in the united states
they are extremely high my brother is a
truck driver with his own rig okay it
cost over a thousand dollars
to fill his truck with gas
what does that equate to
he's gonna have a higher cost for
logistics to transport goods got it
that's going to translate to higher
prices of cost of goods sold absolutely
higher prices of retail
prices and then if you're purchasing
something that costs more today than it
did yesterday then you're paying higher
sales tax for it absolutely at the end
of the day we are all paying for more
on based on the decisions of the current
administration let's but let's let's
wait so
we agree gas prices are high in the u.s
do you agree gas prices are high in
france right now
well france doesn't produce
their own oil but that wasn't my
question darlene is do you agree that
gas prices are high in france
they're not producing oil they're at the
mercy of supply and demand of countries
they can purchase oil from fine
but my question is do you agree gas
prices are high in france right now
they're high everywhere all over the
world beautiful so we can even skip that
part
okay
is joe biden responsible for that
absolutely 100
how why did he stop production of the
keystone pipeline why are we not
producing the same level of oil that we
did during the trump administration
there's a zero excuse on why we can't
produce our own oil hold on a second
though darlene let's take it a step at a
time now because we want to be clear
keystone xl pipeline you know that
keystone xl phase four well i guess
let's back up
keystone xl is four phases
right three of the phases have been up
and running for years the fourth is what
we're now talking about agree so far
right okay so that was 10 000 jobs but
hold on a second hold on a second wait a
second wait a second okay
do you agree that phase four of keystone
xl was not active when trump was
president trump trump wanted to do
construction but it wasn't active
no of course they weren't producing oil
they were not flowing the oil through
that pipeline beautiful agreed 100
do you agree that the pipeline is a
method of transporting oil not producing
it
that is a method of transporting oil but
that also reduces
the cost of supply and demand as well so
you have to factor that in what do you
mean how if they can get the oil to
certain uh markets within the united
states more efficiently that's going to
reduce the cost
of production okay and transporting
correct your economics 101 is a big
thing for you right we're okay
do you know
how much
global oil production would go up
if keystone xl phase four was completed
how much you would go up in what respect
give an example percentage-wise so if
right now we are what we would call 100
right now the status quo is 100
right if keystone xl phase 4 goes live
how much does oil production globally go
up
i don't have the answer to that
why would you
why well i don't know if
that's your fact and i don't think that
fact is accurate no facts are facts
facts are not opinions a fact is a fact
it would go up one percent show me the
evidence behind that fact because i have
not heard that it would only be one
percent i actually think that's
radical liberal facts and people assume
that those are facts so share with us
what is your fact i actually may have
overstated it it might be that that u.s
production would go up one i said global
would go up one percent i think that's
even overstating it i think it might
only be u.s production but it you know
it didn't matter at this point behind
it's only being one percent so impact
everybody from production everybody from
the nrdc
okay to
i mean it's you know
whoever you want to cite we're talking
about a one percent increase globally
that might make a gas price difference
you know that darlene economics 101 and
actually i don't believe in that one
percent i believe that's the narrative
that they probably want everyone to kind
of run with okay
i i find it hard to believe that a
pipeline would only produce one percent
of the world pipelines don't actually
produce anything they're just transport
methods it would allow the transport of
one percent more oil right you just
don't believe it well share share the
facts with your audience share it with
me and then we can analyze it how's that
beautiful beautiful okay
um
what do you think the top tax rate
should be
the top tax rate i actually
i believe as citizens were
double triple and quadruple tax okay so
uh i think right now the federal the
federal
why does no one ever have answers to
these things you know like if you came
to me and you said david sir you're
running what should the top tax rate be
i would be like i don't know i think the
top tax rate should probably be about uh
55
and it would start on incomes above uh
i don't know 5 million i mean like i
would be immediately in the ballpark and
i'm not even running for anything she's
running for something tax
is um
in the 33 percentile when you add
everything together what do you mean
percentile
well when you're looking at how you do
your taxes right yep
it's around 30 plus percent that comes
out of your income in terms of taxes
state uh federal county any local taxes
when you add all that up together well
it depends people think that this is not
a candidate for local office guys she's
running in the 22nd congressional
district in florida this if she's
endorsed by michael flynn and roger
stone and was just photographed with
trump this is one of their best people
this is not some random local politician
what state you live in how much you make
and a lot of things right
correct i was an accounting and finance
major i did my taxes for many years it
was around that that bracket
guys she did her own taxes for many
years so you had medicare tax you add
the med you know the all the different
taxes about that much and then on top of
that you have sales tax and then on top
of that you have gas tax and then you
know if you smoke there's a cigarette
tax um and then you know when you die
yeah there's taxes everything there's
taxes on everything okay so and then
when you die there's an estate tax it's
35 if you have more than 10 and a half
million dollars
no this may be the best part of the
interview okay everybody get the popcorn
actually it's less than that yeah it's
10 and a half million yeah
yeah no it's less than that what do you
think it is
well there's a death tax of like if i if
i die tomorrow
uh before my son could collect any
assets yeah there's a death tax did you
know that that starts at 11 that starts
at 11 your first 11 million dollars
there's no federal estate tax
there's a death tax no
yes where'd you get that
um
there's a death tax that everybody goes
through when you die and you leave your
assets to your heirs right that's the
tax that is going to be assessed
by the government before your heirs get
any money but this is one of the big
this is wild darlene you're a candidate
and it sounds like you don't know that
the first 11.7 million dollars of one's
estate
doesn't you won't you only pay tax after
you leave 11.7 million to your heirs you
didn't know that did you
if it's 11.7
how is it that my because i deal with
seniors all day long from the medical
line okay okay
and i had a i had a client that only had
250 000
and her estate was hit with a death tax
before her children collected it so how
did that happen with her maybe it was at
the state level i don't know but
federally there's an 11.7 million but
hold on but hold on there's a you can
your first 11.7 million
there's no tax federally
right on the federal level okay but you
didn't know that two minutes ago right
right but that's on the federal level
yeah so my i have i deal with seniors
all day long that's what i do for the
last 11 years and i've heard way too
many as a matter of fact this is the
biggest concern that seniors have
brought to my attention
that they have to set up a trust which
cost three thousand dollars typically to
set up about twenty five hundred to
three thousand yeah so that they can try
to protect their assets and not be
subject to that death tax before they
leave their children any money now
wouldn't that be the right thing to do
as someone advising seniors to let them
know that their first 11.7 million are
exempt
well i'm not a tax advisor so that's not
up to me legally to share that
information with them i sell medicare
health insurance so i'm not going to
give advice fair um it has nothing to do
with my life i think that's responsible
darlene but back to the first question
let's focus in on the federal tax rate
because every state has different tax
rates different sales tax rates etc
federally speaking what do you think the
top tax rate should be
i know that there were some
recommendations where people said maybe
we shouldn't have any more than 14 or 15
percent across the board okay
you know i i would love to see lower
taxes i'm for less government and lower
taxes so that's part of the republican
platform um and i'd love to see
everyone pay lower taxes i think that we
should have a much more efficiently run
government i think a lot of the three
letter agencies and four letter agencies
that we have on a national level should
be brought back down to the state level
i think there's a lot of duplication of
efforts so when you look at those
agencies and you look at the number of
employees employed by those agencies and
you eliminate
that
budget
that would be
a completely different financial picture
on how our government could be run more
efficiently
in terms of the tax rate though you
would like to see the top federal rate
go down to 14
i i would like to see it less yes okay
and at what income would that top rate
kick in
i mean if you think about it
realistically you know what and and i
have different look i i grew up poor
okay i'm a true racist success story i
run a very simple are these questions
that difficult like why can't she or so
many of these people answer these
questions
and i know people are like who cares
what she thinks i mean i'm interviewing
her the whole point is to figure out
what she thinks and whether it's crazy
successful company okay
and and i don't think it's easy for
anyone to live
a very uh
you know standard lifestyle if you're
making under a hundred thousand dollars
a year i just think that it's really
challenging with how expensive rent is
sure and mortgage is i mean and it's
difficult for any uh
single income household to survive i
mean it we're almost forced to have two
incomes coming into the home in order to
survive
so i would like to see the benchmark
much higher than that maybe above
250 000 maybe even more maybe four
hundred thousand i mean i i have some
strategies that i would like to
implement
and this is to your point because i know
you wanna stay on point but it's it
touches on taxes okay so now the average
american person that works a blue collar
job or professional job and they're
under that you know couple hundred
thousand a year mark when they work
overtime if they're an hourly rate
person if they work overtime why are
they working overtime they're working
overtime to pay down their bills right
pay down their student debt
they're they're working overtime to
maybe save money to take their family on
vacation
i would like to see the overtime pay not
be taxed
i would like to see the income part of
it still be counted
when when you are looking into getting a
mortgage for example whether they need
to know what your income is in order to
qualify you for a mortgage so i still
want the income to count towards you
know social security income you know
applying for a mortgage applying for a
loan to get a car sure but
but the payroll taxes on the overtime
pay i would like to see that eliminated
darlene that's a very interesting idea
that's a very interesting i i'll be
honest it's the most interesting idea
you've presented so far i would say and
it's not one that i've heard before but
that that's a very and i'm guessing that
this would be for people earning under a
certain amount right we're really
targeting workers here yeah we're
targeting workers that are hourly paid
but you know if you think about it if
they had that portion that wasn't taxed
that additional income and revenue
increases our overall spending to me
that would even improve
the economy that would approve improved
you know people's ability to eliminate
their debt to you know try to get ahead
in a way so i mean i would just would
love to see that idea implemented i also
have other ideas with regards to
reforming medicare and improving
solvency because some experts are
predicting that medicare is going to be
insolvent in about two to three years
that's such a big topic let's not dive
into that right now but at least that
one idea you had that's a very
interesting idea in the last few minutes
we have
um q anon in 2019 you wrote a lot of q
and on stuff on your facebook page you
talked about how q inspired you to run
for congress in 2020. talk to me about q
anon have you taken a so-called q a on
oath
um i didn't write a lot of q anon posts
that's inaccurate um i have a lot of
friends that are you know they call
themselves digital folgers okay and i
actually said that they inspired me to
run for office because to me i feel that
you know we as americans we need to
learn the truth
and they say q and on oath there was no
q on oath it's the oath to protect the
constitution against enemies foreign and
domestic so how do they attach a cue
conspiracy
idea behind taking the oath to defend
your country i actually find that
insulting okay and so yeah it was
general flynn that asked everyone to do
that oath and if you look at my oath
because i did do the oath yeah
i also asked for god's protection and
blessings over our country that was the
end of my oath
my so-called oath got it but you know i
took that oath because you know my fifth
and six grandfathers fought in the
revolutionary war in the war of 1812 and
my
eighth great uncle is benjamin franklin
well what did benjamin franklin do when
he signed the declaration of
independence he said
we either hang together or we hang
separately but we most assuredly will
hang so that's where the term we where
we go when we go all came from john f
kennedy had that on his boat okay john
president john f kennedy had that saying
on his boat can you imagine what's going
on guys this woman is endorsed by
michael flynn and roger stone and hung
out with trump yesterday
so why people are attributing that to a
conspiracy that's lack of knowledge on
everyone's part and they're running away
with that so in other words so you are
not a believer in q anon
i've never said i was that's all
conspiracy related media trying to bash
an america first candidate well this is
why i want to ask you direct so you're
saying you do not believe or subscribe
to q anon
no i i have friends that do okay and i
support anybody trying to find the truth
understood understood that that's uh
that i think is very very important to
know
um okay darlene listen this has been
incredibly illuminating and i can't
thank you enough i think we've had a
number of disagreements you had the one
very interesting idea there about not
non-taxable overtime hours very very
interesting i can't tell you how much i
appreciate you spending some time with
us today
thank you i appreciate that too and i'd
love to see the facts behind what you
shared one percent how that's going to
add to the oil supply i know that's
inaccurate but we'd love to see the data
on that when we publish this maybe your
sources are inaccurate and you don't
know so i'm going to look into it too
and whatever i find i'm going to send it
to you please darlene it's been an
unfettered pleasure on our end okay
so that's that um i guess i have video
of the oath that she took hold on let me
see here
everyone here's my oath
i'm darlene swaffer candidate for u.s
house of representatives for florida
district 22 do solemnly swear that i
will support and defend the constitution
of the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion and that i will well
and faithfully discharge the duties of
the office of which i'm about to enter
as a remnant soldier of god i also swear
to defend and protect our
judeo-christian values i will support
our veterans our seniors and most
importantly our children which are our
future
i serve we the people with humble honor
and respect so help me god
at the signing of the declaration of
independence instead so anyway
this wwg
one thing that's a q anon thing right
yeah wow so listen i mean that was
that was pretty bonkers guys and we we
did it i don't know if people find those
interesting let me know and we can line
up more of them
but it's really scary that these are
people who i mean she she has i guess
it's it's sort of like a biden blue
district that she's running in
but it's not
completely inconceivable that she might
uh
might be able to win so that's really
really wacky stuff
so many people
signed up and are supporting
during that let me just thank a bunch of
people here
um
bajibo
um jen here hanging from gallows hajil
and stevo legend has have just grabbed
twitch prime subscriptions i also want
to let you know if you want a free
membership on our website just go to
davidpakman.com
free membership and fill out the form
these are first come first served we
have 262 people waiting right now
i want to say let's see
um
ressler
just gifted
two more of these
which means that daniel meinelt and
patrick hoover get a free membership
andrew kulp and brian wrestler just did
two more gifts so those will go to tyler
thornhill and corey decker
brian ressler gifting another one that
one goes to mike crowley
has just gifted a subscription that goes
to steve evans
and then i want to say thank you to
chuck blake
and diane swayze for signing up on our
website that puts us at 26 total so if
you want a free membership go to
davidpakman.com
free membership you've got to fill out
the form we're just going to go in order
okay
if you are fortunate enough to be able
to gift some memberships
go to
joinpakman.com and as you go through the
sign up process check the box that says
this is a gift but then just don't send
it to anybody we'll take care of sending
it to someone in need of a membership
okay so that's the deal that's the way
that it's all
uh working
also thank you to snappy tam for the
twitch prime subscription very much
appreciate that okay intent memes and
streams in terms of memes and streams
upcoming
first of all i will be streaming the
trump rally saturday live it's gonna be
an incredible thing and we will
men right so that'll be saturday now
also on saturday i'm going to be
releasing all of the david pakman show
related slap memes let me preview a
couple of them for you now um you can
send these to info davidpakman.com
here's a mute your discord one no we do
have regular problems with people uh
during live calls who are
uh you know unable or unwilling i guess
to mute their discord so that's one
that's been submitted
david's audio and david starting his
stream we have been experiencing some
pretty serious audio issues lately and
it's just my fault quite frankly
but
that's not a bad one and then lastly
nuclear slapping nuclear nuclear
versus nuclear
um if you have your slap meme to submit
and guys to be to be clear remember
i think what will smith did is
absolutely unconscionable going up and
slapping chris rock in the face it's
insane it's completely insane
we also do a show where we want to have
some entertainment value so you know
we're also doing these memes but i want
to be like extra extra clear about that
nuclear slapping nuclear if you make one
of these and you want to submit it
send it to info
davidpakman.com
and we will have like the best best ones
on saturday i want to say thank you to
terry schwerin and derek guin who have
just gifted two more subscriptions on
our website the lucky recipients of
those are chance keller
you get a free membership and emiliano
velazquez
you get a free membership as well for
each gifted membership
someone gets a gift
uh oh and desiree de long also gifting
a membership that's number 30 and we
will give that one to jeevan
magnan jeevan magnan remember
request a membership at davidpakman.com
free membership
send a membership
at
joinpacman.com check the box that says
this is a gift now i want to be clear
if you gift a month membership
the recipient only gets a month
if you gift a year the recipient gets a
year so you know you could be polite
about that or however you want to do
that that's uh that's absolutely up to
you okay let's go to a few voicemails
i'm happy to report to you guys
that after swelling to 1200 unlistened
to voicemails i've managed to shrink the
voicemail waiting line to
827 voicemails
let's listen to a couple and see if we
can uh chip chip off a few more here
gary
the walls are coming down and they're
closing in
on the abiding family syndicate no they
are not
uh here's a random one
hi david what is an investigation on
trump
like what is actually happening to have
that be reported in the news or
considered dude i mean have you ever
heard my show i mean i can't do that
that's that's wild
hello sir so i want to talk to you about
critical thinking in education and it's
interesting
it sounds like you and tim poole
agree that critical thinking is not
being taught enough in public education
i couldn't speak to private education
but it's interesting i wanna i wanna
talk to you about this because critical
thinking
and you probably know this implies that
well you're not only
thinking about the things you're
learning from others but you're thinking
about the system itself and so if we
start teaching critical thinking to
students
they'll start to figure out and realize
how broken our education system is right
and that they won't need to contribute
to it and
they don't feel like they need to be
indoctrinated to it no i don't think
that that's i don't think that that's
the case at all i just i just quite
frankly disagree
hey david it's juan here
you know why i generally don't trust
someone left
because in times of crisis i believe
and this is something i'm pulling out of
my head
that
they want to
be quick
about
wanting to generalize
uh
not generalize nationalize
things
oh my god quan i can't do it buddy it's
going nowhere man it's just going
nowhere
uh let's see what else we got i do have
something from whitney
so
every four years
there's something that looks like a
holocaust it's obese people and we're
done
according to farron cousins the
republicans keep
flashing copies of the hunter biden's
laptop in front of people
if they really had any information on a
accurate copy of hundred biden's laptop
it would have been released years ago
right and
the question is where did they get that
if they got it from russia or ukraine it
was probably hacked before they even got
it
okay
all right well
that's interesting hey david calling in
again
um hopefully it's not totally uh
redundant but
so the right is totally uh to will spam
the right is totally obsessed with this
alpha male
ratio to base amount
and then there's like an additional
layer being i guess cuckolded
they love it so
i think it's important to understand
that that view
of relationships to the world
is childish right they're children
um these are the people that are still
following the bully around man i don't
know what he's talking about and then he
called right back
david i'm not quite sure i have laughed
so hard
in all of my like 37 years and when you
try to replay the monday live stream and
it went on for like probably 35 to 40
seconds of your inability
to somehow connect that replay to the
screen it was without a doubt absolutely
hilarious well i appreciate being able
to provide
some comedic relief that is uh that is
for damn sure
uh let's give away some more memberships
uh derek gwynne just gifted another one
and ryan gunter just gifted one that
puts us at 32
the two lucky recipients are adam stein
you've gotten a free membership and zach
roberts you've gotten a free membership
for every gifted membership on the
website we now have 311 people waiting
for free memberships i also want to say
thank you to george casinga susan hall
lucian berlin
and uh
apparently a second subscription for oh
no no no that's just one okay so that's
three
putting us at 35
very very much appreciate that all right
everybody that's going to do it for
today let me know if you want to see
more interviews like this wacky one and
remember that when we get to 100 000
twitch followers we are going to do a
twitch only town hall
will i ever do a discount yearly code
again we have a whole all the codes work
yearly all the codes work yearly i'll
see everybody very very soon probably
tomorrow and then we'll we will be live
for the trump rally on saturday
hope to see you then